"It's scientifically proven"
"that you can fall in love with someone"
"simply by maintaining eye-contact"
"for an extended period of time."
"So now, you can fall in love with Markiplier"
"all over again in these three locations."
"Happy Valentines Day."
(There is no more dialogue for the rest of the video, so now...onto some fan contributions.)
Look at that beautiful sunset.
The smooth jazz music begins to charm you.
Look at those beautiful eyes...
...as if he is starring straight into your soul.
*Sighs*
He thinks: Wow, how lucky I am to be enjoying this beautiful sunset with you.
*Head tilts*
How are you enjoying this moment...
...with such natural beauty...
...and this sunset?
This view is pretty nice.
But not as great as the view I am having...
...of you.
*Crosses arms*
Say...
Do you think this could be
the start of something magical?
Because you are absolutely bewitching.
Do you feel the chemistry?
Because I certainly do.
God damn it Mark, stop nodding and smiling
Are you happy being here with me?
Because I certainly am.
You make me the
happiest man ever.
*Sighs*
You are the most wonderful person I know...
...and you know it.
Sometimes I can't believe that I have
such a wonderful person like you in my life.
I don't mean to brag, but...
...you are the only one deserving
of the love that is Marikplier.
I guess that was a compliment.
*Sigh*
I guess we were just meant for each other.
There could not be two people
better for each other than us.
You know all those dreams you have?
Well, I am the man that
can make them come true.
(Insert Lenny Face Here)
Did you do that on purpose?
Hellooooo?
He's just staring at us...
... and making small smirks and stuff?
I'm actually concerned...
Are you okay Mark...?
Don't tilt your head all cute like!
Three minutes in and we're still watching...
k nvm, this is pretty intersting
Don't sigh boi
At least the ocean is nice
...
This is just weird. Stop it Mark. (Edit By Another Person: MARK IS NOT WEIRD, HE IS MARK.)
Mark...
I feel like we've grown closer these past 3 and half minutes..
Stap
It was in this moment a murderous thought popped into his mind, and he shewed it away without you even knowing
...
The FitnessGram Pacer Test is a multistage aerobic capacity test that progressively gets more difficult as it continues.
The 20 meter pacer test will begin in 30 seconds. Line up at the start. The running speed starts slowly but gets faster each minute after you hear this signal bodeboop.
A sing lap should be completed every time you hear this sound. ding Remember to run in a straight line and run as long as possible.
The second time you fail to complete a lap before the sound, your test is over. The test will begin on the word start. On your mark. Get ready!… Start. ding﻿
you feel yourself getting lost in those markepleyes
Can't look away
I swear this man gets more beautiful
Cute lil laugh :3
Could a human get anymore perfect???
Help him, i think he's mute.
I feel like... his trying to tell us something.
"You know," he thinks
"Everything about this person is beautiful"
"Damn. I wish they would say something about my hot bod"
"Yah, they may be on the other side of the screen, but I still love em."
Crap. I fell in love
Almost there...
oooo~
Are we going somewhere??
'Bout time
Doggos!! Look at them!
Oh yeah. Mark is still looking at us.
Ummm..
Your hair looks nice.
It was at this moment you realized,
...that all this video is here to do is...
...make you "Fall In Love With Markiplier"
The shirt looks good... * awkward cough*
At least the dogs are cute...
Then you saw his face...
...and thought...
Naw, Mark's my favorite puppy dog. ^v^
Don't do that..
His shirt is so nice though..
Don't do the eyebrows.
How dare you.
This man is so beautiful.
You think the people back there know that there is an angel sitting right here?
There are like 6 dogs back there
You start to look over every aspect of his body...
...then thought...
"LOOK AT THOSE LEGS"
don't sigh on me.
Your gaze drifts to the left...
...as that dog butt captivates you...
*sniff* so good.
(A doggo races across the screen)
Nod.
CHICA
Chica save us
At least she's happy.... But Mark's just.. Mark
Look at that smile.
Chica, come.
AHHHHH
giving that V neck affect ;)
Notice how beautiful his eyes are
Dogs!
aww the slipped. but he gets  back up!
Butt sniffing train
Cute smile
The dogs.
They play.
~intense eye contact~
AW! the doggos are playing!
Doggos
Chica why? You're scarin' him..
Chica D:
come back D:
Mark, watch your dog...
why are you still watching this?
You wonder to yourself why you exist
While you stare into his eyes...
...watching...
....waiting....
.....hoping.....
.....For something other then this.
(Mark acts cute)
I'm pretty sure no one is paying attention to Mark at this point
Aw! A decent smile.
Mark, what are you implying?
All abord the doggo express!
Wonk!
Cute nod
The smile of the century
Uh
Focus is 95% on doggos
damn I'll admit that stare is pretty sexy I mean what-
This is weird Mark.
ooooo~
Are we going somewhere else??
Well HELLO There
How YOU Doin'? ;)
Why.... It's so weird..
Adding some bubbles~
Das a lotta soap
STOP IT MARK
At this point you're probably googling "How to delete a Youtube video someone else posted"
Why?
End our suffering
I don't think you need more soap....
Are you done?
Smell that beautiful fragrance
Only the highest quality for Markiplier
I swear if you drop that..
ah yes a nice cold d r i n c c
Don't open it in the tub!
*Yeet*
That flinch tho
Treat Yo Self
No.. You'll spill it :(
You're going to spill!
Just another casual night
To us!
How did you not mess that up?
I'm slightly impressed.
How are we still watching this?
(Drinks casually in a bubble bath with fake candles)
delicious :|
Dont drop it!
So... You look nice...
This is awkward Mark.
Okay but who agreed to film this and why
Shimmy shimmy
Still don't know if i should call for help
Mark?
You ever think about the meaning of life?
. _ .
I wonder what he's thinking about...
You know...This isn't exactly how I imagined it...
Not Like I've Thought About It Or Anything!
I mean this is sexy and all but..
I'm sure a rubber duck would make this a lil more fun
Wot..
Why more bubbles??
Why?
Oh come on
(Intensely stares while pouring more bubbles)
A bold move sir
That's too much
You'll drown in bubbles at this point
Gotta love a man in a bubble bath
Mark isn't acting like himself, let's fix him with a controlled shock
I feel so bad to who ever is new to his Youtube
i keep waiting for something, anything to happen. maybe for chica to jump into the tub.
Too many bubbles Mark!
What are we doing with our lives...
*Swish*
*Swoosh*
*Sploosh*
eyebrow raise
Phew
Like and Subscribe??
And we will see YOU in the next video!
maybe.
I think we should make a run for it
I was expecting Darkiplier or something but ya know..
Theory: what if this Is Darkiplier? Remember in ADWM Dark was jealous that Mark took you out on a date and didn't invite Dark? So this is his version of a date, that's why its so uncomfortable
Hear me out tho, Mark said he wants us to fall in love with him, and Darkiplier during ADWM wanted you to "let him in"
Enough theories, let's just stare some more..
...